uh this story has has lit me up jack was
just mentioning that like my segment at
four i was going crazy i'm like i'm like
yelling into the camera check this out
from timcast.com prosecution reprimanded
by judge for quote grave constitutional
violation during cross-examination of
written house judge schroeder also
dressed down the prosecution for
attempting to bring in evidence that he
banned from admission this is where it
gets crazy
in the trial i'll give you the gist real
quick
the prosecution said evidence that
occurred uh
you call it evidence i don't know an
event that occurred four months after
the night in question is not admissible
because it has nothing to do with him
defending himself and so they're like
okay
the prosecutors started bringing it up
anyway and the judge got mad angry he
got pissed but the craziest moment was
when the prosecution asked kyle
rittenhouse why haven't you told this
story before until tonight and then he
says you waited until everyone testified
so you could tailor your testimony and
then it was boom objection the judge
goes off he's like what do you think
you're doing you can't you can't do this
you can't question someone else to their
right to remain silent you know this
you're he's like you're an experienced
trial uh prosecutor
when the second violation came up he
snapped he's like i can't believe i was
astonished that you would dare bring up
something like that is a matter of basic
law for 40 50 years and then the
prosecutor is like you know when it came
to the question of the evidence he was
bringing in the prosecutor's like you
open the door your honor and he's like
for me not for you don't you get brazen
with me
i was shocked and here's it gets really
crazy the i didn't i didn't think was
going to happen
the defense said that if this persisted
they would file a motion for a mistrial
with prejudice meaning that the
prosecutors aired or or attempted to
break the rules to prejudice the jury
against written house to such a degree
he would never have a fair trial and
that the judge would have to uh dismiss
dismiss with prejudice meaning they
could never file these same charges
again
surprisingly
they when when they put uh kyle in the
stand he ends up he starts crying he's
breaking down when they come back the
craziest thing the defense
actually files the motion asking the
judge for a mistrial with prejudice the
j this is when the judge starts getting
into with the prosecutor he says i will
take the motion under advisement and
then essentially says if there's one
more violation to the prosecutor
so people are speculating now saying
what might happen is that the judge and
the judge has actually said this he uh
to something something this effect he
doesn't want there to be a circumstance
in which he intervenes and shuts down
the court proceedings he wants the jury
to be able to come to their findings but
there's speculation and i don't know how
valuable the speculation is that there
could be a directed verdict meaning that
as a matter of law the charges against
kyle rittenhouse
are impossible to to get when you had
kyle rittenhouse according to to uh the
state's witnesses himself and everyone
as he was yelling friendly and fleeing
the scene you can't get intentional
homicide on that
but the judge didn't rule it and people
are saying maybe he wants to see if the
jury will rule correctly he might
intervene after the fact so you can tell
him really amped about this totally yeah
i thought i was listening to your your
segment on 2x on the way up here man you
were going you were hyped you know one
of the things i keep thinking about and
i've seen some other people ask about it
is this court case is being televised
and it's clear that the judge is at
least neutral if not i don't i don't
know he seems he's at least neutral
right he's not biased he's not clearly
got a left-wing bias
how many times across the nation over
and over and over again are prosecutors
doing these things that are
unconstitutional
and getting away with it and even just
having the judge basically on their side
as a way to put people away that they
think are political uh you know sort of
you know on the other side of the
political spectrum i'm sure from what
i've heard from julie kelly and other
people covering the january 6 stuff that
uh if the judge this judge here the
written house judge was there in in dc
or wherever they're trying these january
6th stuff that it would be going a lot
differently oh yeah uh it brings up you
know the idea like maybe every single
court case should be televised so that
we can see every single thing that's
going on so that these people can be
watched
it's kind of scary to me to think that
people that guy an experienced
prosecutor who clearly knows about the
constitution i've read from other
lawyers that this is a subject that
comes up a couple of times in law school
plus it's on the bar exam you can't you
can't bring up the fact or use it
against them that the guy didn't speak
after his arrest and yet there he did
just as the judge said brazenly
violating this guy's constitutional
rights in the letter and in the spirit
of the whole thing how often is this
happening all across the country this is
a prosecutor who knows he has the the
mob the rioters and the press on his
side
and
even after all of these grave
constitutional violations so the judge
said the media doesn't cover it the
media the media uh just says like kyle
written they frame everything to the
worst degree for kyle kyle cries on the
stand because he probably killed the
guys is the headline well uh the daily
beast said murder kyle right now makes
wild accusations about those claiming
they were threatening him and i'm like
wild accusations there's multiple
witnesses saying that that rosenbaum
said if i get you alone i'll effing kill
you that was that was this yeah the
state's own witness saying he drew his
gun on kyle rittenhouse and the daily
beast lie false frame i'll say they
falsely frame look i wasn't there
obviously i wasn't there but that was
one night that i watched as many streams
as i possibly could i watched bg i
watched richie i watched one guy even
aggregate like three or four streams
into one
so like i was there when uh that guy
became the n-word guy remember like not
there but like i was watching at the gas
station oh yeah rosenbaum yeah when rose
and bob became we were just calling him
the n-word guy because we didn't know
who he was because he was running around
screaming the n-word he was obviously
agitating he was looking for conflict
i'm going to get you i'm going to do
this
and like the people in the press and
popular interpretation
just did not experience that the way
that the guys on the ground obviously
did that written house obviously did and
then those of us were watching it
intently actually experienced it that
night yeah framing is everything because
you could take certain facts and you
could emit some of them you could
highlight some of them and you know
there's different stories being told but
the fact that this case is being live
streamed i think is absolutely amazing i
think we should livestream all of
criminal court cases just so we could
actually get
an unbiased point of view to what's
actually happening here but it was kind
of wild seeing the state prosecutor
literally argue more with the judge
interrupt the judge more than he did the
defense i was like what's going on here
there was a number of times the judge
snapped on the state prosecutor who
looked like he was a deer in headlights
for many of the uh proceedings so again
the mainstream media attacking kyle is
nothing new they've been attacking him
from the very beginning we didn't even
know a lot of the details here the
mainstream media came out with a lot of
spin on this story and highlighted
specific events that fit their narrative
now there's another narrative there's
you know talk about some of these people
who who were shot their criminal past
their criminal history people are just
selecting and picking whatever fits
their narrative but truly seeing this
live raw unedited i think is extremely
important and i think we should
normalize this uh as much as we can yeah
i mean aside from being on the ground i
watched it live from multiple streams
i've interviewed richie and bg on the
scene i was just listening to the
podcast that we did with them uh back in
the summer time uh it's one of these
things where like i i have such
almost firsthand experience and you know
i wasn't there but like to see the
discrepancy between what happened that
night talking to eyewitnesses watching
the trial and then seeing what's
happening in the headlines like how
where did they even get the white
supremacists this and that i mean
they didn't even
yeah they're all tweeting that cal
written house killed three black people
what right like
okay hold on hold on not everyone but
there's some elements on twitter and
social people on twitter are pushing
this that theirs and they're not getting
fact-checked at all there was a a a new
york lawyer account with like quarter
million followers who tweeted i have not
been following this in my new detail but
i think the fact remains kyle
rittenhouse crossed state lines with an
assault rifle to go to a protest and i'm
like
the prosecutor has charges against
dominic black for supplying a weapon in
wisconsin to kyle rittenhouse that's a
substantial portion of the criminal
proceedings out of kenosha these people
don't even understand what the
prosecutor is going for in this they
just made something up they all tweet
about it they don't fact check they
don't watch the trial and then they
claim they did i've been sitting here
every morning with it on livestream on
tv and then just like reading all the
legal analysis from like rocato law and
from andrew branca and a plethora of
other uh you know legal analyses
watching all these live streams and i'm
not going to pretend to be a lawyer no
right all of the the nitty gritty
details and the law the defenses citing
various laws that were violated by the
prosecutor i can just tell you the judge
screamed at the prosecutor
for a grave constitutional violation
he said he was like you're on the border
line you may be over it
i was actually he cut himself off too
he's like and then
i'll just i'll just leave it at that for
right now you want to know why i was
pissed i was listening to rickety's
stream and it was fantastic rakita had
70 000 viewers on his stream it's it's
really really almost like tim cast oh
yeah i mean but they're that's way
bigger than we've been in this past year
i mean and so their commentary is
fantastic and i don't know who it was
but they made the comment that
the judge
does it doesn't he wants to prove that
these trials can happen that the process
can work and as soon as i heard that i
realized if the judge does not declare a
mistrial with prejudice he proves that
prosecution can violate your
constitutional rights prejudice the jury
by admitting evidence that was deemed
admissible and the judge will allow it
to happen but if he has this dueling
incentive of a wanting the jury to rule
on the facts and perhaps come back with
a not guilty verdict at the same time as
wanting to protect his constitutional
rights and the in the process and such
and maybe then go to this direct verdict
that's a that's a tough one for the
judge to actually manage it it is it is
but i think
some people have speculated that the
judge will wait for the jury to issue
their finding and then intervene you
imagine
it happens but i mean can you imagine if
they come back and say guilty on all on
all charges and the judge is like
yeah yep the reaction is going to be
absolutely that would probably be the
worst case scenario and then i mean the
chicago police department already put
out a notice saying uh for officers that
their leave is not um going to be
approved because they want all officers
on the force because they're expecting
civil unrest to happen in uh major
cities so already there's a lot of
threats there's a lot of hyperbolic
language on on social media that's not
getting fact checked that's not getting
corrected that's being escalated that's
being promoted uh so this is building up
to uh another recipe of disaster
especially with the mainstream media
putting fuel on the fire in this entire
situation blatantly lying about it
there's a there's nothing i'll address
that right yeah dude go for it you
mentioned the rock in the hard place of
the judge
i thought about that i'm like if he
intervenes people will claim there is no
fair trial
but if we watch prosecutorial misconduct
malicious prosecution when there was a
guy's name debrew and i think his name
was do you see this the witness who
testified that ada krause and binger
brought him in and told him to change
his police statement right malicious
prosecution that was on ziminski i think
his name is
mt joshua not on written house but these
guys are clearly corrupt if the judge
says i'm going to allow this corruption
to play through
then then
unfortunately the system is broken
maybe this isn't the a team either i
mean if you if you grow up and your
biggest goal in life is to become the
prosecutor in kenosha wisconsin does
that mean that you're that you're the 18
prosecutor no offense to kenosha or
small towns around the country or
anything but maybe maybe this is just
standard you know
incompetence that we see and i mean i
have no idea i haven't sat in on too
many murder trials in fact the one that
stands out to me is is oj this is all
reminding me a little bit of the oj
trial i was in college you guys are
probably too young for this but i
remember the whole country was watching
man and in fact like the i remember i
was in class at university it just
stopped the day the verdict and like it
was such a big deal we were all watching
it i don't think that this has that same
level of national prominence but just
along among politicos oh yeah definitely
people like us
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time